este es nuestro módulo receptor
infrarrojo de 38 kilos hertz que
funciona con nuestro control remoto
universal que pueden ver aquí pueden ver
cómo se enciende cuando presionamos
botones diferentes y es el mismo control
remoto que desarmamos en nuestro vídeo
de ingeniería inversa
vamos a colocar nuestro receptor en la
tarjeta de prototipos y lo vamos a
doblar hacia atrás y esto lo hacemos
para activarlo desde diferentes lugares
de la habitación
ahora vamos a conectar la patita que
está en el lado izquierdo viéndolo de
esta manera al pin digital número 12 en
nuestro arduino así que esto lo
conectamos directamente hacia atrás
ahora vamos a conectar las otras dos
patitas la del centro y la de la derecha
a nuestra terminal positiva y a nuestra
tierra tenemos una terminal a tierra en
nuestro arduino por lo que colocamos un
cable negro de nuestra patita de tierra
hasta este terminal en nuestro arduino
aquí estoy viendo que el cable tenga la
longitud correcta
y está conectado con la patita central
del receptor también cable a mos nuestra
patita positiva a nuestra fuente de 5
volts la patita positiva es la de la
derecha vamos a probar nuestro receptor
pues previamente cargamos código a
nuestro arduino oprimimos nuestro botón
hacia adelante y vemos que se encienden
los motores así que está funcionando el
código lo proporcionaremos en los vídeos
que tratan sobre él arduino